so there's a recent paper
by pickering and gerdrick uh the title
is
is coffee a useful source of caffeine
pre-exercise
and uh basically what they what they
concluded i'm jumping
right to the highlights here they said
there's limited evidence
that caffeinated coffee has the
potential to offer ergogenic effects
similar to those of caffeine anhydrous
which is basically just
supplemental caffeine
at first i read that and i thought they
were saying like that there's a lack of
evidence i think what
what they're getting at is there is some
evidence but it'd be great if there were
more
that there aren't that many studies
looking at coffee specifically
as an ergogenic aid but what we have
would indicate that it is pretty
equivalent
uh in terms of its ergogenic effects
um and what they also noted was that
co-ingesting caffeine with decaffeinated
coffee
so if for some reason a person in the
world were inclined to
have decaf coffee and mix some caffeine
into it
um the decaffeinated coffee does not
detract from the ergogenic effect
of the caffeine now the only reason i
bring this up we've talked about
caffeine plenty on the podcast
the reason i bring it up is nerds like
greg will always talk about
you know it's just a single study let's
wait and make sure it gets replicated
and all that stuff
right single study you don't want to get
too carried away
this is a perfect example so in 1998
graham at all did a study and they
tested several different treatments
it was a placebo a caffeine capsule
alone
regular coffee with caffeine in it just
a normal cup of coffee
decaf coffee and then the final
treatment was decaf coffee
with a caffeine capsule okay
all of the treatments aside from the
placebo obviously
and the decaf coffee provided 4.45
milligrams per kilogram of caffeine it's
a pretty standard
ergogenic caffeine dose the only group
out of all of those that improved
was water plus a caffeine capsule
so the regular coffee didn't work and
the decaf
with the caffeine capsule also didn't
work
and so what they theorized was that
something in the coffee was inhibiting
the beneficial effects of caffeine and
they they thought maybe it was the
chlorogenic acids but i mean with coffee
it's like take your pick there's like
hundreds of bioactive compounds in it we
essentially ran with that conclusion for
like 15 years
to the to the point that as late as like
2010 in review papers they would say
like
yeah if you want to get an ergogenic
effect it can't be from coffee
you got to get the good stuff the
caffeine anhydrous so
this is like a a real world example of
where
for i think about 15 years we took this
one study and said well
looks fine to me and just went with it
and then it wasn't really until 2013
that a few studies started
reinvestigating that question
and it kind of just went the other
direction you know
there's still we could certainly use
more
data related to this particular question
but from what we have in the last few
years there have been more studies
coming out
there's one by hodgson at all there's
one by richardson and clark
my lab group did a paper on the topic
and generally speaking what we find with
some of this more recent research is
that
caffeinated coffee seems to be just fine
in comparison to
a caffeine supplement which intuitively
makes sense but is actually
uh a controversial take or at least it
was up until about a couple years ago
so this is a real world example
of uh when
people like greg want to be a stick in
the mud and they say
hold your horses let's see if that
actually replicates this is an example
of that however
i will uh note that um
pickering and gargic in this paper they
bring up some good points
there are some challenges with coffee if
you're using coffee and trying to get
ergogenic doses of caffeine
sometimes that requires you to ingest a
pretty high volume of fluid
so for some people that might be
annoying pre-workout having a bunch of
coffee
obviously you can go to some uh you know
more concentrated coffee type products
with higher caffeine content but
another thing to keep in mind is
variability of caffeine content so
the type of bean how it's roasted how
finely it's ground how it's prepared
all of these things go into the actual
caffeine content
of the coffee you're drinking so if
you're trying to get an exact ergogenic
dose for a really big competition that's
something to keep in mind
um and a great example that is a study
by mccusker at all
they got the same product from a coffee
shop six days in a row so
same product same location it was
starbucks right
i believe so yeah and uh of those six
days the lowest caffeine content
of this product was 259 milligrams
and the highest was 564.
so um that's a hell of a range i mean
those are two very different experiences
from that cup of coffee
right so um it's something to keep in
mind if you're gonna use
uh coffee as a regular ergogenic aid i
do
you know i think it's fine uh but if
you're like
let's say it's day one of the olympic
trials and you're trying to make sure
you've got your
your caffeine dose perfectly titrated
then it might make sense to go with
something else
um brand new study that is not super
relevant but i found it
fascinating this came out like a week or
two ago
by fukuda the title is habitual coffee
drinkers
uh may present conditioned responses
from coffee q
and this was a study in i believe it was
in the field of psychology this isn't
like a performance fitness type thing
but
i found it interesting the sight and
smell of coffee alone
they didn't ingest any of it they
basically were just like okay
smell it you see it hear some coffee
take it away
that alone appeared to enhance
performance on a simple reaction time
task
in habitual coffee drinkers so it was
one of those things where um
if you believe that your love for coffee
has gotten to the point where simply
being in its presence is a positive
thing for you
apparently these people got a benefit
from just
smelling and seeing it